one of the most lavish parties on new
year's eve 2012
started aboard a rented 747.
[Music]
the jet which was turned into a casino
flew to australia where attendees
including leonardo dicaprio and jamie
foxx rang in the new year aboard a yacht
then they quickly bundled back into the
747 flew to las vegas at the highest
speed possible
and were shuttled to a nightclub where
they were able to do the countdown again
they basically beat the clock despite
its celebrity filled guest list
this was no hollywood production the
host was a malaysian financier
joe lowe his fortune made the whole
thing happen
it also allegedly came from what appears
to be one of the biggest heists in
history
the 1mdb scandal the people who were
alleged to have
done this theft allegedly stole four and
a half billion dollars
that's a lot more than even some of the
worst dictators in history have stolen
lowe isn't alleged to have done this
alone goldman sachs and some of its
bankers are said to have played a key
role
the bank has just reached a
multi-billion dollar settlement with the
us government for its involvement
it touched wall street it touched
hollywood it went to vegas and there's
the most
powerful investment bank on the planet
right at the center of it
so let's take a look at the scheme that
allegedly helped fund that party and
many others
the players that allegedly benefited
from it and the fallout for them
and the bank as the plan began to
unravel
from the start 1mdb was a very strange
animal 1mdb which stands for one
malaysia development berhad was a
sovereign wealth fund created in 2009 by
prime minister najib razak
though it was low's idea and he ran the
fun behind the scenes when we think of
sovereign wealth funds we think of
a huge pot of money the savings account
of a country
but one mdb was part of a new class of
sovereign wealth funds that were kind of
in vogue
so the idea is you borrow money you're
paying the interest on it but the payoff
the benefit from the money you bought is
so much better that the economy is
better off for taking on this debt
1mdb touted big economic development
projects
including turning malaysia's capital
city kuala lumpur into the wall street
of asia
to borrow the money needed one mdb's
leadership turned to goldman sachs
and tim leisner the bank's chairman in
the region for goldman
there's two things at stake here there's
a lot of money
one mdb is willing to pay them uh huge
fees to raise money
quickly and quietly there's also this is
a new frontier for goldman
in asia they think there's going to be a
lot of investment a lot of economic
growth and they want to be the us
investment bank that's leading the way
in total goldman raised six and a half
billion dollars for one mdb
through three bond sales in 2012 and
2013. but what stood out were the fees
the bank collected on these deals
on the three deals goldman earned about
600 million dollars
that's ten times what banks typically
earn on bond issuances
it was a total red flag right it just
didn't make sense as we got deeper and
deeper and deeper into it
the more it didn't make sense
prosecutors now allege that some four
and a half billion dollars of the money
raised
was stolen siphoned off by low leisner
and others
but it would be another two years from
the time the bonds were issued before
the scheme
started to unravel when it really got
our attention though
was what i like to think of as the first
island on the archipelago
of scandals in 2015 the wall street
journal reported 1mdb
paid what appeared to be an inflated
price for power plants in malaysia
the fund purchased these assets from a
company that then used the overpayment
to make a donation to a charity chaired
by najib
that charity then used the money to fund
schools in districts where najib needed
votes
and then within weeks we got a tip
and we were able to get documents that
showed that
nearly 700 million dollars of money from
1mdb found its way into the prime
minister's bank account
and that was explosive to this day najib
denies wrongdoing
he previously claimed the 681 million
dollars was a donation from the king of
saudi arabia
but after the news broke the federal
bureau of investigation initiated a
probe into the affair
everybody knew that there was this one
mdb scandal kind of boiling there was
this scandal with the charities
but you couldn't connect them that's why
it was an archipelago with increased
scrutiny on 1mdb in its spending the
journal reported in 2015
that a 1.4 billion dollar payment 1mdb
had said it made to its partner in abu
dhabi
the international petroleum investment
company had gone missing
that payment was said to have been made
to an ipic subsidiary called
abar documents provided to the wall
street journal show that a payment was
made to abar investments limited
only problem there is no abbar
investments limited within the corporate
structure of abbar
and that was something that became a
pattern through all of our reporting we
found that there was these look-alike
companies frequently used and
that was a big revelation for us as its
scandals spread outside malaysia 1mdb
was struggling to repay more than 11
billion dollars in debt
because the money was stolen it wasn't
invested without investment returns the
fund couldn't pay back the bonds
eventually all of the islands in the
archipelago were connected when the
justice department
issued this huge complaint where they
explained all of the money flows that we
couldn't see behind the scenes
and low was allegedly at the center of
it all this guy
who was by all rights the mastermind
behind the fund
was buying luxury condos in new york and
london
he was throwing these you know crazy
parties in las vegas
and there was a pattern of behavior with
him and some other people that made it
clear
that um you know money came from
somewhere
and then there was this
low was also the financier behind a
little-known movie studio called red
granite pictures
which was run by najib's stepson with
the money from low
the studio made the wolf of wall street
this is the greatest company in the
world
it was never clear exactly what lowe did
at 1mdb and why he was even there
in investment banking you never want
someone hanging around the hoop who
doesn't
have a good reason to be there
especially when there's public entities
involved
because it's often a sign that someone's
getting a take
but those days are over in october low
agreed to forfeit more than 700
million dollars in assets u.s
authorities sought to seize
including real estate a luxury yacht and
a private jet
according to a settlement load did this
without pleading guilty
and has denied any wrongdoing blow is
also missing he's a kind of
one of the world's biggest global
financial fugitives
and based somewhere in china though we
don't know entirely where
as the scandal unfolded najib was able
to squash some of the investigations
internally
but in 2018 he lost his bid for
re-election
his opponent ran on an anti-corruption
platform
matt then unraveled everything for najib
they raided his house
they found boxes of cash they found
millions of dollars in jewels
last month the malaysian court sentenced
him to 12 years imprisonment and fined
him nearly 50 million dollars
in what will be the first in a string of
cases against the former prime minister
najib has denied wrongdoing and his
lawyer said najib would appeal the
court's decision
as for lysner he is no longer with
goldman he pled guilty in 2018 to
conspiring to launder money and violate
foreign anti-bribery laws
he'll likely be sentenced but in the
meantime he's cooperating with the us
government as a witness
against other parties including his
former employer
for goldman this scandal may have just
come to a close with the bank agreeing
to pay about 2.8 billion dollars to the
us government and admit wrongdoing
according to people familiar with the
matter this settlement follows one
earlier this month with the government
of malaysia
where the bank agreed to pay two and a
half billion dollars
it's not an accident that the investment
bank at the center of this
is goldman sachs it's a firm that prides
itself on
being a little bit edgier and it has
worked out remarkably well for them
for a long time but every 10 or 15 years
it blows up and it always blows up in
sort of an unpredictable
way even with goldman's settlement the
1mdb saga continues
much of what mdb's missing billions is
still unaccounted for
and the only one i think who really
knows where everything
is is jolo and he has no interest in
telling anyone at this point so
a lot of that may stay secret i think
it's going to take a long time and we
may never know the full extent
of what happened in 1mdb